[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are going to be talking
about the things that scare us the most
why is it that we only get to be scared
in October I don't know the way culture
works but apparently if you're in the
business business of being scared you
got to talk about it in October but man
you know it's there's um there's a
holiday at the end of the month and it's
called
Reformation day Reformation day I mean
Halloween you know yeah it's it's that
time of year people I understand if if
you're one of those people who is like
a little strange and like has something
deep inside of you that's like a s like
a seed of Darkness that at any moment
could explode into like some sort of
tree this is strange this is all people
man somebody who hasn't like who's not
too religious who's like oh this is my
favorite time of year you know this is
for you peeps love ya okay first of all
let me just I feel like there was some
exclusionary language there uh so I want
to backtrack over some of that stuff the
first thing being that I want to other
you a little bit weird
uh calling these people a little bit
weird incidentally I just recently saw
in some people like that were presented
at the YouTube Summit
we can't shut up about it uh I think
more than half of it is I think it might
be like the most popular sub-genre of uh
movies right now amongst the general
public also I think that everyone has a
seed of Darkness inside of them some
people have just made friends with it
hence Reformation day uh and then what
was the last thing you said that was
occlusionary oh not religious actually I
have always been a fan of horror movies
even and I'm actually one of the things
I'm going to talk about I think my
religious past plays into the way that I
think about it and some of the people
that I know who are still very very
religious considering themselves very
very big horror fans because I think it
makes it that much more visceral and
real I'm just messing you know some of
the nicest sweetest people I know are
horror Fanatics because they they get it
out just like some of the nicest
sweetest people I know are really
hardcore heavy metal fans because when
when you've got a form of entertainment
that is a release like a really into
screamo or you're into like hard death
metal you know the traditional
understanding of that culturally or like
is to be scared of these putting a hole
in your like body and then stretching it
real far yeah people who do that kind of
stuff in my experience tend to be the
sweetest most well-adjusted people
because because they've again they've
made friends with that side of
themselves and understand it's like
everybody's got it in it he's the nicest
person I know he must have a penile
piercing yeah those of us who have
denied that that is a part of us it's
just sitting there and it has its way
with us we don't control it you need to
make friends with it so you can control
it it's in there if you don't make
friends with it it controls you it's
like having a pet or having like a
predator that lives with you it's like a
Mogwai or a gremlin yeah which I was too
afraid to watch
always that's what basically ultimately
like what I'm getting at here what I'm
implying is that you have yet to make
make friends with the dark seed inside
of you I think it makes you a little
unpredictable and potentially a serial
killer I've made a list that's the
number one thing you know you've made
your list on my list of the things that
scare us the most I guess I should put
the number one thing on my list is that
my Doom seed will germinate
like what's gonna happen
yeah you know uh because everybody's got
one also know I have this side of me
that like that can be impulsive and not
you know I thought about putting that on
the list am I afraid of myself everybody
should be a little bit yeah everybody
has within them the potential to one day
have a psychotic break and run down the
street naked everyone has the potential
for that right if you have a psych then
you could have a psychotic break and my
belief is if you are a heavy metal fan
you are the least likely to be the one
running naked down the street that's
just my anecdotal Theory Channel it
release it what do you think about that
Jenna
I know plenty of metal people and I I
mean some I've seen them
running naked down the street
intentionally or as a result of a
psychotic break I'm just saying these
are different things yeah yeah yeah
probably it's intentionally yeah right
yeah yeah there's nothing wrong with
streaking yeah in fact I I I'm an
advocate
hi yeah I'm due for a good streak do you
know that I need to get struck I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna name any names here
but somebody that I know Bob who is
currently in college uh I was recently
talking to them uh is it not my son just
in case you're wondering and there's a
tradition my daughter no there's I'm not
gonna let you narrow it down but it's
not either one of our kids but there is
a tradition at many schools of streaking
there's an area of a of a camp of a
campus where there's a tradition of
streaking like you what you run from
here to here yeah and I was on the phone
talking to him and I and he was telling
me about well yeah we I was like what'd
you do to celebrate your birthday it was
like well we went and we went streaking
and again it's just like that's
something you do and when it's
intentional and it's not the result of a
psychotic break uh that's a different
it's a different story yeah
yeah
you know I don't
yeah I was about to mention names but I
won't go in that direction it's going to
make fun of a certain country music
singer but I like the person I don't
want to make fun of them
I know you're talking about so instead
I'll say yeah actually Lily and her
freshman year you know very early on she
she reported that there was a there was
a streaking uh cavalcade
I think it's important she didn't
participate in uh as a freshman but hey
she's a sophomore now you know well
incidentally in the footage that you
uncovered from our College days that we
showed some of them right on uh the
mythical Society
is me and Greg streaking not uh in any
like place on campus but in our
apartment complex from the apartment I'm
I said if you guys will strip down naked
and let me film you streaking then I
will
join you guys in shaving my head
and then um I was shocked to watch the
footage because we did not try to frame
it in such a way as to not show any junk
flailing yeah oh and when I say we I
guess I mean me because I was filming
and so I was like oh my God I can't I
can't give this to employees to edit
yeah right there's junk flailing yeah
it's pretty blurry
yeah I pride myself on having unblurry
junk but I was not streaking at the time
it was nice very crisp it was 1996 and
you were using a handheld
DV and it's like the footage is 20 years
old so what do we want to do let's get
let's get into the fears because I I
like it when we each have made our list
and we can surprise each other this is
this is more your jam so uh you should
go first
um I'm gonna start what scares you more
I'm kind of starting in a more expected
territory with uh demons and uh okay
again I it is amazing how first of all
they just keep putting out horror movies
and my experience with horror movies is
I go to watch horror movies with now
with Shepard because he's the one that
will watch them with me Jesse won't we
go to the theater quite a bit
and we'll watch a horror movie most
recently Barbarian which I wrecked
because I loved it and if you go see a
horror movie especially if you go to an
AMC theater what do they do before the
horror movie they show you
15 trailers right so every horror movie
that's coming out
and then my typical experience is
because I tend to then go to Rotten
Tomatoes to see is this worth my time is
this worth me and my son's time
is that
eight times out of ten which would also
be four times out of five
they're so low ranked like these horror
movies end up being in the teens
sometime and you're like man that that
it looked like it was gonna be so great
but the trailers really get you in the
mood to be scared right and oh I find
myself consistently frightened by The
Exorcism ones and I'm not talking about
the Exorcist I'm talking about all of
them so there's a movie
I don't know what the name of it is it's
probably out now by the time we're
talking about this but they've been
rolling the trailers and it's about this
uh nun who is like studying you
basically get the whole movie in the
trailer but she's studying uh exorcism
amongst these males who he was a men
only like priesthood Catholic priesthood
training and then it let her in to this
class not because she's going to be a
priest but because she's doing I don't
know what the premise is but she's in
this oh yeah glass ceiling
because see I went to the Jordan peel uh
movie and I saw this trailer too yeah
and it's she's the only one who can do
it and and then there's like this thing
where her mother was a bit nuts and it
turns out well her mother wasn't nuts
her mother was possessed and this demon
has been trying to get into her for all
this time and it's there he's in this
little girl that they've got in the
bottom of this like church and
I the scenes are just chilling to the
Bone and I first of all they do the
classic thing which has always scared me
is anytime you pair anything like scary
and Supernatural with a little girl
I thought that was going to be a
separate thing on the list scared of
little girls you tell my little girls is
not on your list little girls who are
possessed by demons so that is it is
inclusive well that's of and again this
is probably some uh unresolved misogyny
or whatever you see this little girl and
you're like oh this is she's not a
threat she she couldn't do anything to
hurt her hurt anyone and then but when
the devil gets inside of her and she
puts on a little dress and her head and
starts spinning around I it just it gets
me and I am so frightened by it so the
so you're really saying demon girls even
possess girls you're not just talking
about demons but I mean it's scary when
they go into dudes too man it's just not
as scary okay okay I get it but let's go
there I want to come back to Demons in
general but let's let's keep going down
this path so you're going to see that
movie well I'm gonna look at the Rotten
Tomatoes I remember back in the day I
bet you it got me to see the ring with
you there's a there's a good there's a
girl in that well Jesse and I had that
co-dream that I talked about on the
podcast I talked about it on GMM I had
to go back and listen to that to really
get the details but then I have since
not gone back and listened to it but
essentially there was a little girl in a
dream in my dream a nightmare and I woke
up as a little blonde girl and then
Jesse woke up from a nightmare and she
had been dreaming about a little blonde
girl and I swear that we had some little
demon in our dreams man now here's the
thing what do I actually believe about
this let's let's go there because right
because that's the I thought that's the
deeper question when you said demons I
was like well
I I was
presuming that what you were going with
here was like
these scare me the most in movies like
possessions and stuff like that because
I can't I you know I'm it could be real
like the spiritual realm demons
possessions this stuff could be real
that's what makes it real scary
yeah and that I think that's what really
ingrained it in my mind as a kid was
seeing the Exorcist trailer when I was I
remember the Exorcist Exorcist trailer
coming on while I was watching
television and I felt like I had to get
out of the room you know I was like oh
no no no no no no it was overwhelming
and because at that point it don't come
through the TV man at that point there
was absolutely no question in my mind
that this stuff is real right it was
like of course demons are real now we
were in
you know like a Baptist Church at the
time where it's like nobody's getting
possessed I mean maybe somebody's got
like a demon of gluttony or something
because they're going to the buffet too
much you know what I'm saying like the
way that but it's how many times has he
gone back to the church potluck table
it's not a there's not uh in the same
way that there is in like a Pentecostal
or a charismatic now when I did go and
work with cannabis crusade in New York
City for the summer of 1998 we worked
with exclusively charismatic churches so
these are mostly black churches uh who
are doing the inner city work up there
uh and I did witness uh an exorcism oh
there was an exorcism in the Next Room
well like a lot of like yelling and
screaming and then like a girl went into
a room there was some music during the
surface uh uh yeah yeah so there was a
there was a you said it was a girl
yeah she did but it wasn't she wasn't a
woman and she was a teen there was okay
it was a teen yeah and she was scary she
was in the service what she brought
forward as this teen
so we it wasn't that simple we arrived
as it was in process and we heard stuff
going on and then like she kind of walks
out and she looks like she's been crying
which again oh wow my personal at the
time here let me just be honest with you
at the time
I thought no that's both she was that's
not a demon that's what I thought at the
time because I was like because dude
I've seen the demons in the movie man
she's not spitting peas there's her
voice didn't change and since then
spitting peace
anything you eat you gotta in the in in
the in The Exorcist she spit I mean it's
green I don't know if it was peas oh
you're talking about vomit yeah but
clearly Supernatural things happen
that's what makes it super scary however
I have watched many exorcisms on YouTube
because I'm kind of into it and really
um there's there's a guy in South
America who is pretty famous for doing
exorcisms and uh there's a there's a
British YouTuber I can't remember his
name who went down there to investigate
I told you about this when do you yeah
when you tell me stuff like this I act
like I'm listening but I'm I'm going
into I'm going into flight mode okay
great I'm I'm in our free mode here's
the thing I can't listen there's nothing
to be scared of there's also that uh are
you can you describe what this situation
is when you're watching this are you
like in a doctor's office waiting room
just watching exorcisms before you go
back to get your mole checked are you
like turning all the lights off
like are in in like your basement I'm
well to be clear I don't watch exorcism
content on the internet to be scared
because it is definitively not scary
what's it like it's fake oh oh
okay that's the point I've been trying
to get to this whole time
is that no there's but there's plenty of
exorcisms that
even if it's not real there is no
exercise there is no exorcism that has
ever been recorded on video that anyone
is doing anything that a normal person
couldn't do just acting weird and that's
why there's no evidence that any of this
stuff is real as far as I've never seen
any evidence that it's real yeah but the
girl who came out of the room
do you think she was an actor at that
church you went to no she was being
emotionally manipulated that's horrible
well is it really I mean yeah it is it
is hold on hold on what do you mean it
is horrible but I'm saying emotional
manipulation happens in almost every
group of people that you can possibly
come up with I'm doing it to you right
now it can be more intense and I do
think that there's spiritual abuse that
happens in that what I'm saying is that
it's a it's a it's a charade that
everyone is in on and everyone believes
it's not dishonest I think that that
girl thought she was possessed oh and I
think that these preachers who were
doing it thought that she was possessed
it's not an act that's what you believe
about speaking in tongues yes people who
are charismatic Christians right who
could speak in tongues no longer believe
in Christianity and still can speak in
tongues because right it is a human body
is amazing the stuff that we can do our
mind is so flexible we can convince
ourselves we can hold two disparate
thoughts at the same time I'm not
surprised at all about any Supernatural
experiences that people claim to have
had and I'm still open to the fact that
they might be real and that's why it's
still scary to me because I'm like well
it might be real and there's always
going to be a part of me that's like it
might be real I'm just saying that I've
never seen anything that would suggest
that there is stuff actually happening
that can't just be explained by people's
Mind Playing Tricks on them but hey I'm
still I'm open to it I'm still looking
into it and that's why I watch I'm just
fascinated with religious culture in
general that's why I watch a lot of
preachers on YouTube and these guys who
are who are exercising people they're
the most entertaining of all there's one
guy isn't even Bob
Love Bob something and he's got a cross
and he puts it on your forehead and he's
got a Bible and it's like this dude is
freaking intense and again everybody
thinks that it's real and Bob probably
knows that it's it's at least somewhat
deceptive but at this point he's in too
deep
all right
um I want to give a shout out to
Stevie's podcast it's back for season
three best friends back all right with
her High School best friend again
they've reconnected now they talk about
all sorts of things and I'm very excited
about the fact that yeah she's Stevie is
going in well for her birthday
she is going to be opening a time
capsule I don't know when it's from I'm
guessing it's from like grade school she
made it in grade school she's going to
open it and go through it on the podcast
yes uh so yeah they've they've expanded
there
might be a demon in there because she
was a little girl when she made it so
yeah I love that idea
um watch that episode or listen to well
listen to it along with us wherever you
listen to your podcast best friends back
all right yeah shout out to nagine okay
what do you got maybe she's got a time
capsule too well don't look at my list I
can't read from here because this
um I I was making notes
um
like when I was in the car and I didn't
have time to pull up a new note so this
is my Note with my potential DJ names on
it and I don't want you to see them oh
wow because
I I have decided that I am
revealing my DJ Persona including my DJ
name at methicon mm-hmm
and I I'm making a list and um
I you know I I will say the first name
on the list
I'm not gonna use it so it's I'm not
going to use uh DJ dope nuts I'm just
not gonna do that sometimes you got to
just get through some names right just
like you know a list is kind of like not
no no no bad ideas until you've read
them back that's the first one that's
actually the first one dope nuts dope
nuts yeah nuts with a z nuts with two
teeth no but that two T's in a z might
do it
I don't want to do anything with an
alternate spelling that's one of the
things that I've decided
so I'm gonna I'm doing a DJ set at
mythicon if you if that's what's going
to put you over the edge to buy a ticket
to mythicon October
um what is it 29 20 30 29th 28th and
29th go to mythagontickets.com you can
experience along with everything else
the dance party that I will be DJing as
my DJ Persona we're kind of bookending
uh mythicon James and the shame is doing
something on the first night and you're
closing out the the basically the dance
party with I do have dope nuts whatever
the DJ I I'm excited I don't want to
build I don't want to build it up too
much because you should because that's
how that's how people get excited about
things right Mythic on tickets if we're
gonna you know
we're we're reaching capacity
and you know what if you can't make it
we're gonna live stream we've told you
this we're going to live stream our
stage show but we're not live streaming
DJ dope nuts no or James it's not going
to be dope nuts I'm using don't call me
that I'm using it's not me as a
placeholder that's not me
ddtbd it's better than DJ TBD call me
that DJ TBD for now
or just TBD DJ
well how does this relate to your fears
um well the the first the first one that
it's just I made the list
for the things I'm afraid of under my DJ
name list that's what it has to do with
it homie okay homie I thought you're
afraid of dope nuts
no
um dangling dope nuts that that might be
my first um I don't know DJs don't
release like mixtapes maybe they do
maybe they do who cares you make the
rules man who cares yeah it's a pirate
you know it's a lot of a lot of
Licensing involved
um
I mean I got to go with the most obvious
thing that I'm afraid of at First Blood
I mean I'm J I'm simply afraid of blood
but it's not like yes I'm a it's I'm
afraid of the circulation of blood the
concept of blood circulating like I'm
afraid of getting like if if I if I try
to take my own pulse I just hate that
hmm I mean and it's kind of ironic
because it's kind of the sign of life
it's a really good sign that there's a
liquid coursing through tubes in your
body but when I touch it and it like it
pulses and just it's
it it makes me quiz I just get queased
not
once the Blood starts coming out you're
also queasy right because I think that's
the most yeah that's the place where
most people begin to say okay but if if
like if your finger was bleeding I
wouldn't faint but if it was the result
of a cut if it was squirting blood the
circuit is the circulation is worse than
the bleeding
just a side of blood it needs to be
paired with something like a visceral
injury Chianti
no it's like
um
an injury or circulation
like it has to be paired with something
it's the one-two punch of this blood is
associated with this thing this movement
through my innards like I don't like
anything related to surgery like cutting
people open exposing this insides
putting the insides on the outside
that's that's gross
I think that's why I don't like dog
erections
now that I think about it because it
looks like the inside coming outside yes
I don't think many people like I don't
think dogs like dog erections they do I
mean why do they lick it uh they're
ashamed
I didn't mean to go down this path I'm
sorry
um
any in of course there's the there's the
Timeless story of me opening the Barbie
doll at Christmas and cutting my finger
and then at my father-in-law's house the
in-laws house and then running to the
kitchen sink and then the next thing I
know I'm coming to in my father-in-law's
arms
because
my finger was cut because and it's so
like having a like creating that like
crevice that ditch that like oh how deep
is that like I mean cut if you see bone
oh my gosh oh I can't stand it and like
so yes seeing gross like that in a movie
is just it just seems I don't like nasty
I don't like that stuff in the movie and
then I don't like you know I don't like
seeing it in uh medical dramas either
like I got a freaking turn by the way
like for I'm a huge horror fan but I
don't think I've ever watched like Final
Destination right you know which is just
people dying in a bunch of weird ways
like I I kind of get it and I would if
you ask me to go I'll go to it and I'm
not gonna get freaked out you're more
psychological but yeah I don't like gory
is not like I wasn't a kid that saw
those Gore magazines like uh what's the
name what's that one that was always in
every stand in every gas station we went
to jugs no that was different
um anyway
I I am not into that at all I I think
most people would agree with you on this
there because every time you sometimes
you meet like a doctor an emergency room
doctor especially
and they just don't find any of this
stuff gross and they yeah right they
those are the people that we need I
understand I can understand how you can
get to that point or be at that point
where it's like hey you know what some
people might find you know everybody can
find something scary or gross it's like
oh look at this like
black like furry material coming through
my epidermis on my forearm oh my gosh
that is just horrible not that gross to
somebody it might be but it is an
exposure thing I think a lot of medical
students the first time they see a
cadaver the first time they they slice
open a human human body
the first time they're in surgery for
real
I think you get you get a tolerance I
mean not everybody just starts I
freaking deleted my entire list
well is that a fear of yours
what the hell
how did you do that
deleted my freaking DJ name list
with all of my scary
what shake it
what you mean hit undo
yeah
undo
hold on there was a I saw a capital P
yeah I'll show you again
no now it says redo
redo there's a p oh man what was the P
for oh did you do did you highlight
everything while talking and then I
would type over it I think when I
sneezed I deleted my DJ name maybe
they're not important
well I can remember one DJ don't know
like whatever remember I mean oh my God
all right DJ dope nuts in the house
maybe he's fate maybe I have to call
myself DJ dope nuts now yeah well we
also have TBD TB DJ DB DJ now this is a
notes huh notes of it's a Notes app and
it's in airplane mode right now oh great
great great yeah go to Okay Okay Go Okay
stop right now take it off airplane no
no no no no
this is exactly the kind of thing that
you would do
go get your laptop right now copy the
note into a new note
yes copy the note into a new note call
it something different I'm not gonna do
it right and then it'll be okay
it'll be okay oh you're saying so I'll
have the rest I guarantee because I need
to know what I'm afraid of 100 sure that
as soon as this podcast is over because
you're a creature of habit you're gonna
take your phone out of airplane mode and
you will forget I guarantee you there's
a 100 chance you're gonna screw this up
if you don't listen to me right now
maybe I should just call myself djp
that's the only thing on this freaking
note now I go you need to go get your
laptop because you also need it because
you got your list of fears you don't
remember all of them can you go on
without me yo I think I can handle it
you know what screw you screw you man uh
what you mean let's try that again
hey here we go Jenna's gonna get it can
you go on without me I doubt it man I
doubt it I really doubt it I really
what's your level of certainty that you
doubt it uh I've you know I'm very
unsure I'm you know I'm afraid I'm
afraid of going on without you that's
one of my top fears
man okay let's see if this works guys
this is this is happening
this is happening this is this is I this
is my fear man you you know you work so
hard on something yeah yeah and then
you're like you work on a document you
work on a document and then it doesn't
save yeah and if you're like using
Google Docs or something it's it's
constantly saving that's the best thing
about using the cloud and look I'm
proving it right now well the thing
about notes unlike Google Docs if you
did this on Google Docs you could just
bring up a previous version but notes
doesn't have that so you get I don't
know if you and I was using other things
in notes and then Evernote was trying to
sell me on all this other crap never
know it has previous versions I'm not
paying Evernote for something that
evernote's constantly creating multiple
notes of my notes because this is that's
my thing about stickies aren't notes
I've never opened notes on my computer
oh hold on you've never opened notes on
your computer oh this might be trouble
oh
you only use stickies welcome to notes
you don't use notes notes are way
different than stickies I I used it on
my phone so now it's gonna go and try to
sync it's sinking right now guys yeah
but what's it syncing with
you've never opened notes so it's not on
here bro
[Music]
so go to I go to all Cloud all iCloud
I don't think I'm logged in as my
is this the best podcast ever this is
dramatic
stick with me
if you believe that we can get through
this yes so what do you need to do
I need to figure out how I'm logged in
well hold on
to the notes what folder are you is this
are you on just on my phone
here we go
I'm in my iCloud account and I'm looking
at all I know it's not there so that's
the iCloud account that's on there so
that's not your primary iCloud account
you need to go to your your Mac address
iCloud account and it'll have them so
this one's the Gmail and if it doesn't
you really are screwed
are you gonna have to just start from
scratch my Gmail
DJ scratch that can work I'm sure that's
been taken all right so now
I'm gonna I'm gonna sign in with my
other account
now this is the most uh Adventure we've
had on this podcast in quite some time
someone's yelling out there
their computer right now of what we
should do I'm sure
[Music]
well if it wasn't synced to begin with
it could be difficult at this point
yeah but his phone should have been
syncing with it because it says iCloud
and it's got and he's got multiple notes
in there I just don't know why his I
think his his
uh the computer for some reason is nice
here we go I'm in my other iCloud
account all right here we go this is
going to be clicking on notes
DJ names DJ dunk nuts is back baby okay
DJ TBD create a new note don't and don't
read these I'm not reading it don't read
my DJ names read a new note and just
copy it over I don't smell great anymore
more the right pit than the left now
again and before you turns out I'm
pretty scared okay listen before you
start referencing this create a new note
and copy it over you have to do that
first
the same thing
no no create a new note first
well I'm gonna let's not panic okay I'm
not I'm just trying to taste
DJ names two is what I suggest
okay and I would do t-o-o
because it's cool DJ names t double o
there we go
crisis averted oh my gosh guys thank you
for hanging with me
I want to let you know that I just lost
six months off my life
but and and now I'm reading a list of DJ
names and uh I don't think any of them
were worth the trouble
uh but let's hear your next your are we
going like I just don't think next fear
I just don't think DJ cheese profit is
gonna
it was worth all this trouble
when did this list happen last night
yeah last night you know it's just kind
of like
um I don't know that hey what do you
think I mean you know I don't want to
know uh I don't want to know I think
profit cheese with no DJ could be cool
yeah I don't I I'm working within the
realm of not using the term
yeah it's 2022 man yes I just want to
have a moniker yeah because it stands
for disc jockey that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard
well now that this is here I'm just
going to use this all right y'all we're
back in this I'm afraid of blood I'm
afraid of injuries let's move on to your
next one on the list okay uh
shake your phone and then that's the way
to how long has that been a feature
oh okay man a while
uh donkeys have existed I am afraid of
medium-sized groups
okay are you talking about as a person
is this like you I don't think you're
talking as like uh social anxiety I
think you're talking about like are you
talking about in like as a in a
performance I think it's social anxiety
okay because I definitely know if you're
performing if you're like addressing a
group a small group or a really large
group it's easy but when you're
addressing an awkwardly medium-sized
group from like a stage then that's
nightmarish uh and I don't I stages are
very comforting to me so uh separation
the
you know get I'm nervous before a stage
performance
the nervousness
melts away completely as soon as I'm on
the stage and in front of the crowd like
that's when that's when all of the
anxiety goes away I'm like now I'm here
I'm doing what I what I'm supposed to do
and of course when it's like
go like I'm going out to dinner with
there's six people or eight or eight
people in this group of friends and
we're all having dinner together like
I'm very comfortable there
but if it's just like okay 16 people
and now it's like okay we're gonna go
around the group oh we're gonna go
around the group and we would like
everybody to talk about the last time
they really felt
insecure or any I mean any kind of
question where it's like okay now I've
got parties are you going to yeah I mean
that's never actually happened I'm just
imagining and then you have to
it's just this weird in-between so a lot
of our fears are things that never
happen uh no but this has happened I
mean there was a moment there
um yeah where we were
a pre-pandemic
where the the people that and this is
kind of an LA thing intentional
friendship communities yes and like you
might find like I went to a Thanksgiving
thing oh I don't want to hear about that
again I've heard about it too many times
and but no but there was a let's go
around the horn and say something yeah
and it's not like it isn't Mama die and
Daddy Mac's house when you go around the
horn and say what you're thankful for
that's I mean I'm not this is like you
don't know it yeah like I don't know so
you're saying it's at least 16 people
and it's it's it has to be comprised of
strangers to you know what at least 50
strangers
um I think that that's part of it
and I think that let me and let even if
you're not doing a circle share let's
just say I mean are you afraid if it's a
if it's just a a mingle party okay
I've never thought about this I'm
thinking about it out loud so help me
process this I think that this is the
problem for me
I have essentially two modes
right
I'm like a robot with two modes this
model has two modes okay and one mode is
I'm amongst friends and I am it's a
small group
I and then the other mode is I am in
front of a crowd and I am performing and
I think most of my friends would be like
those are two very different people I'm
not like I don't if I'm hanging out in a
small group I don't draw a lot of
attention to myself I don't like start
making jokes and like do funny things I
just it's never been my personality to
do that now occasionally if I'm like
somebody asked me to tell a story or
I've got something I really want to tell
y'all I'll kind of go into like a little
bit of the performance mode but I'm very
rarely in performance mode or like oh I
I'm gonna throw my dad on the other hand
is like if he's in a small group he's
like throwing out one liners making
jokes all the time I make jokes and do
one-liners when me and you are doing
comedy together on this podcast on Good
Mythical Morning in front of a big group
and that is very much me and it is but
then there's this Middle Ground where
I might not perform it feels like this
group is large enough for me to go into
performance mode but I don't feel
comfortable going into performance mode
so I'm staying in this sort of more
intimate I'm in an intimate conversation
mode but now I have to speak in a way
that addresses more than 12 people and
it puts the it puts me in the robot
inside me that is two modes is like
which mode do we assume and I don't know
what to do and I think it just makes me
uncomfortable I don't have a
medium-sized group mode that I have like
fallen into
I'm either performing
and you're supposed to look at me and
you're supposed to to listen to the
things I'm saying or I'm just kind of
hanging out and I'm sort of like just
just a person that's just talking to
other people
in the middle is is is where things
break down for me yeah I'm trying to
figure out if if I can relate to any of
this specifically I don't and I just I
don't know I don't know if I do I
definitely like I do have a sense of
social anxiety but it's always this like
for me it's the expectation it's not
being in the
in the mix it's it's leading up to it
and it has to do with things like
am I late have I have I forgotten what
day this is have I synced my notes am I
way too early
you know that type of thing is DJ dope
not the good name or a bad name
yeah I mean sometimes you got to say it
up you got to say it really a hundred
times your every name cheese profit
cheese profit yeah uh so is it profit as
in like making money off a cheese or a
profit making proclamations about cheese
I hope is the proclamation making
proclamations okay the uh you know what
if there's 12 people
there okay if you go to dinner for some
reason it never happens at dinner
because what happens in a dinner table
is you have a Zone you talk to the
people in your Zone unless it's a
private room
and we're all going around and talk that
then it can become then those dinners
that's why that's happening yeah
Thanksgiving it seems like you don't
really like the going around the table
thing going around the circle no I'm
using that because what it does is it
highlights the specific Dynamic I'm
uncomfortable with
all the attention
from a group of 12 to 18 people or let's
go 12 to 30. well I wouldn't say 30
because the unique classroom size and I
always loved being a Class Clown I
didn't have social anxiety it's like 12
to 20. okay 12 to 20 people
and if you're speaking everyone is
looking at you and looking to you and
then I'm that's why I don't know if I
should I go into performance mode you
know should I let these people know what
I'm capable of yeah you know or or
should I just be a normal guy who's just
being
honestly between to to like what Groove
do you fall in because
you're just being honest and isn't
trying to be funny or perform or impress
you in any way yeah but maybe a little
funny he's not trying to entertain you
but the one the me that's trying to
entertain you I'm super comfortable
there I actually don't feel like one is
less me and one is one is more me I get
that it's just a mode for a setting
next one on my list
um oh you're ready to move on DJ profit
well we got it we got so many like no
it's fine it was just a funny way to
move on I mean I was done go ahead
can I give my
were you done where's that I mean that
was that seemed like it was I was done
it was just a little bit of a heart as a
guy who's an inspiring DJ I was saying
it was a little bit of a jarring
transition your thing is supposed to be
like listening pleasure us into the next
thing so it's just something to work on
ah thank you once you get your DJ name
I'm sure it'll all work itself out I am
whatever it is I can guarantee you no
one's going to be happy with it at first
yeah that's that's a good name right
that's a good name yeah I because I
think I've already picked it out
okay from the list
all right
but I wanted to keep the list so I could
always say these are the ones that I
almost went with so I'm glad I got it
are you going to focus group this
amongst like me
well I know you're not or is it going to
be just like I don't I'm debating that I
don't know I really don't know yet okay
it's just too early to tell all right it
doesn't I don't have to be in the focus
group I'm just saying I don't I could be
a focus group
all right I I'll be honest dope nuts was
uh Christie's idea
which you know kind of puts it in a new
light right oh wow okay I know right I'm
kind of you know kind of a compliment
um
I'm afraid of cutting my dog's toenails
oh yeah oh you can't catch me doing that
uh I had a fear of getting my own
toenails cut as a child and um you know
uh my stepdad had to hold me down by the
ankles so that my mom could trim my
toenails and it was just it made it a
lot worse did he sit on you
no he's sitting on you and then holding
his your ankles out in front of him he's
kind of grabbing my ankles okay I mean
that made it traumatic but I I mean what
else were they gonna do put me under
you know take me to a groomer how old
I'm not being uh just I don't know early
memory I mean still maybe I I still
might have been six
I don't know I'm not faulting them at
all I think that's like at a certain
point you gotta you gotta cut the
toenails I mean
I think you could send them out and have
them run around and then naturally wear
themselves down yeah like on the
concrete I try to I try to take Jess
he's got this freaking nail that's like
I would I guess it's the thumb the
thumbnail it's way up here it like it's
not it's way far away from the rest of
the pause and that toenail will curl up
in a complete circle if you don't cut it
yeah it's back for when dogs had a post
and it's very loose it feels like I
could grab that toe like little
vestigial toe and the nail and just like
pull the whole thing off and there's a
little bit of a bone but but don't
there's a little bit of a bone in it and
it just feels like it's not attached
grosses me out like what what was it
what did it do at some point I think I'm
afraid that you cut them too close and I
think I was just afraid of and I was
probably really Wiggly and I did get
some blood draw oh I was saying what is
the post what is that oh that's the
point of it like it's obviously it's
there for a reason it's
no it used to be a thumb it's what it's
nothing it's festivial it's there for it
was there for a reason yeah so dogs had
thumbs or the ancestors of dogs had
thumbs that they did stuff with they
open Candy they have a fifth they have a
fifth metatar why did it move up because
they didn't need it it's just like we
can run faster without this and then it
goes away like uh
um Jasper has them on all four legs but
Jade only has them on the front too and
future dogs won't have them at all Jay
doesn't have them on her back legs at
all isn't that wild yeah and then what
you know by the time that our dogs
evolved they'll be Hooves dogs aren't
really evolving because we're doing it
artificially no I was just saying
hypothetically yeah so um and then
whenever I snap the the thing to cut
their nails
Jasper Yelps even though it doesn't hurt
it's just the idea because it he's just
like me and I feel for him but I don't
like sending my dogs to the groomer
because they smell a lot better when I'm
washing myself and it's like a special
thing we have so I don't want to send
the dog to the groomer just to get their
nails trimmed Sean we would take him to
the to the groomer to get his uh
toenails cut and he along with being
groomed right and he bit the freaking he
bit the groomer so he's not allowed to
go to the groomer yeah so now you're in
my boat man don't bring him to me
because that's what I'm afraid I think
I'm afraid of cutting toenails I'm not
afraid of cutting my own toenails
for the record oh you got over that I
got over that yeah when you're in
control of it it's it's way easier I'd
much rather cut my own toenails than I
got a a pedicure one time because yeah
Jesse was like you triggered me and I
was like yes that brought it all back
what part of this do you enjoy this is
torture it's ticklish I'm laughing the
whole time I didn't laugh at all I mean
my toenail I cry you got to get like
they bring out special extra tools to
get through my toenails
you know like oh we were not prepared
for this bring out the wall system you
know wall with an eight I saw a um I
think it was a tick tock of this like
feisty Chihuahua put in a sling like
picture like a hammock type sling and
there's four holes where the where the
the legs go through and you just like
growling the whole time he's like
growling like trying to get to him and
there's nothing yeah and then they're
just no toenails and it's like it's good
for everybody they should put you in one
of those at the pedicure place it's like
your feet are coming out of here I'm
growling it's like you're right there in
the middle barking at the lady uh what
are you afraid of I'm afraid of snakes
and this has gotten I realized recently
that this is I'm afraid of snakes too I
can't believe I yeah that's on my I'll
put it on my list it's
affected me deeply and okay but do you
hold the I'm no let me on the show I'm a
lot more afraid of snakes than you are
this is a weird complex fear and and let
me I'll I'll elucidate because you hold
Craig I'm not afraid of I'm not afraid
of a snake I'm not afraid of if I if I
know a snake is there
I'm going up to a cage somebody hands me
a snake I'm not I'm a little bit scared
the whole time that like even holding
Craig that like I've seen those videos
where they just they just reach up and
bite you and their little teeth mark get
get all over your face and stuff and you
bleed like crazy ah I don't like the
idea of that and so I'm a little bit
scared the whole time but not too scared
to touch them
and uh I have had a recurring dream for
many years haven't had it that recently
where I'm walking through some
environment usually tall grass and
there's snakes everywhere and this ties
into the way my fear has manifested
itself in real life now growing up in
North Carolina we spent a lot of time in
the woods
next to the river next to the creek we
would walk indiscriminately through the
woods
yeah without ever thinking about snakes
and you know what we saw snakes we'd be
swimming in the river and we'd look over
and there'd be like I remember down in
Keith Hills at the bottom of that last
Spillway there was a bed of I think it
was probably water snakes and I don't
think it was moccasins but like I'm
talking 40 snakes slithering on top of
each other like Indiana total Indiana
Jones we would like stick a like Golf
Club in there and they were
long they were big and it could be they
could have been six foot long and I
stepped on a water moccasin one time
when moving the canoe and jumped away
and he didn't bite me
but what I have found is that I cannot
enjoy hiking in California really I
can't because of rattlesnakes
yes but then I went back to North
Carolina
um last year and was walking through the
woods with Jesse and I realized
I was constantly thinking about snakes
really and I was like
in this super focused like looking
around and being like don't step on a
snake don't sneak up on a snake and I'm
like why why is this fear manifested
itself now hiking in California
when you go up in the mountains over the
summer I went hiking four times in a row
I saw a rattlesnake four like four hikes
in a row I saw a rattlesnake but they
are reclusive and you gotta really get
them cornered for them to do anything to
you there was one
on the trail and the rest of his body
which was weird and like an ambush
situation but he kind of slithered away
I don't know why this has
I don't know what happened I don't know
what happened to me I don't think about
I'm I'm so afraid of snakes and when I
go hiking I just do not think about that
because I want to enjoy hiking well I
want to enjoy it too but I'm thinking
about snakes I think my my love level of
compartmentalization is like super
human like I think that might be my
superpower huh
what if you because DJ compartmentalizer
or just the compartmentalizer actually
that sounds like a show on ABC
like stars a teenager you know like a
teenager doing an adult job solving
solving um
he likes talks directly to an angel he
has to be solving crimes though
yeah but he's like he's doing it through
his expertise in like storage
equipment yeah he just owns a storage
facility
the compartmentalizer I'm afraid of
snakes too man I'm afraid of spiders I'm
afraid of bugs I'm afraid of lizards I'm
afraid of any little thing that like
creeps or crawls or has multiple legs
[ __ ] multiple legs I had a lizard drop
the tail on me
he dropped the tail
you know how they Panic they can just
drop their tail so it'll start
squiggling around and they run away from
it just separate from their tail they
have an ability to snap their tail off
this was you know you know those you
know I didn't know they could snap it
off I thought it had to be pulled off
well I don't exactly know the mechanics
but I've always here's what happened I
was in the garage and I just cleaned the
garage I was very proud of myself
and I was like man and I'm like spraying
uh like mint you know you can do like
mint spray to get insects from keeping
so you don't have to like do like
pesticides oh like ants and stuff yeah
and any kind of bugs you know I'm like
I'm sucking up I'm like sucking up all
kinds of I'm just going around and
sucking up uh little spiders and I know
people don't like it when you kill
spiders but you know what I kill spiders
I kill if bugs get in the house I kill
them sorry I'm that guy and so and you
know you're a Maverick the best way to
do it is with your shop vac just suck
them right up yeah surely they probably
die slowly inside of the Shop-Vac but I
also don't care I bet there's a lot to
eat in there and so I think they make a
little community of friends before they
all die slowly but I suck them up in the
thing just reverse it and just blow it
into your neighbor's yard
more than I care about the community of
insects that live inside my shop vac
here's the thing
I was looking at my amazing Immaculate
garage and then all of a sudden I saw
one of those lizards and it was a big
daddy sometimes they get real big and he
was doing the thing where as soon as he
saw me he played dead now
let me be clear I don't kill lizards
it's just are you fine with picking them
up nope
as a teen either as a team I'm younger I
killed lizards I killed snakes
I mean I've killed squirrels and rabbits
too I would a BB gun I was a little
terror and um
and we did eat them sometimes when we
could convince my mom to cook like a
rabbit in the house which we did one
time
she like braised him you're bringing it
you're bringing a little the tape did
you bring the tail of the lizard to
Jesse and ask her to cook it no I didn't
so this thing's staring at you but I
don't kill any animals other than
insects now I have evolved okay it's
plain dead it's playing dead but I like
I can't I'm not gonna touch this thing
because they bite man they bite and this
I'm scared of them they look like a
snake with legs yeah and so I got the
broom he was not even responding to the
broom he was like I'm so committed to
this oh wow but then it like the third
stroke of the broom he woke up panicked
and went right back into the like the
little crevice area where the other
broom was just leave him alone and I was
like no no no no because now when I'm
coming down here in the morning to do my
stretches I know that you're hiding over
there and you're gonna run out and bite
me on the nose
or something I wouldn't have stayed
there and so I took the back end of the
broom and started poking back they're
trying to get in a move and he is like I
see him and I'm not trying to poke him
I'm trying to scare him flush him out to
get him out of the garage
he does a maneuver and then all of a
sudden bam I'm looking in two different
places because he's done his thing the
tail broke off right at the base and
this was a big sucker his tail was three
inches long his tail breaks off and
begins to do this acrobatic dance that
is if you know what it works my God this
is fine I'm focused on this this
evolutionary adaptation worked because I
didn't see where he went I was too
focused on the trick
and it that thing moves when it detaches
it just keeps wriggling for three to
four minutes
wow
three to four minutes and then I was
afraid to touch it I left it there for a
day because I didn't have a Kleenex that
is so disturbing
and you know what I know that like what
other animals I mean I'm I'm afraid of
all those little things what else I know
that you're afraid of bees I'm not
afraid of bees I'm not afraid I don't
know what it is I'm not afraid I just
believe I'm not gonna get stung by a
like a yellow jacket a b especially a B
I am not afraid of bees it would like
what about a wasp
uh I'm I I'm I'm not gonna sit there and
eat lunch with water they're done
demonic I'm not gonna mess with a wasp
but like a bee or a yellow jacket even
like those little yellow jackets that
come around your food but they don't
sting you man you can't handle it hold
on the little ones that's that's
different a real yellow jacket will
sting you in I know I'm talking about
the little things the little ones that
aren't actually Yellow Jackets yellow
I'm not scared yes you are and you're
afraid of bees I am afraid of bees yeah
I'm Not Afraid no but a b can land on me
and I'll keep eating not to the because
you don't you don't put that in energy
into out there and then the bee won't
sting you that's not my experience man
and then honestly if they do how many
times you've been talking about bees not
that many no not that many I've been
stung by several bees that's because
you're being erratic no you think
they're interpreting no yes I'm saying
that like there's multiple times
threatening them I'm a bee friend a bee
landed on me I love bees and stung me
because they don't have mouth legs
they have arms
they have arms y'all
and you're also afraid of bats is that
on your list you're definitely afraid of
bats dude you didn't put it on your list
all right comprehensive list we've gone
through the animals I think yeah yeah
snakes bats bees spiders
lizards multiple eggs
um I asked Lando before I dropped him
off this morning what is he afraid of
and he said oh and this was a big one
for him he's afraid of mascots and I was
like that's a common fear it's a comment
I'm like why are you afraid of mascots
he's like because I there's a because I
know there's a person in there and I'm
like but they don't talk and he's like
yes and and he said in their facial
expression never changes it's like
it's a silent it's so creepy like
mascots are freaking
creepy I was like oh you know what I
should be afraid of mascots I'm gonna
start being afraid of us that's a that's
a good cogent again argument so this is
what it's like to have link as a dad you
come to him with a fear and he just
adopts it as opposed to helping you with
I'm I am now afraid of mascots man uh I
I find mascots creepy I I think that if
you don't find mascot it's a little bit
creepy then there's probably something
wrong with you or you're a you're a
Disney adult but I think that you do Mo
most kids when confronting with a mascot
will cry hysterically
and I think Atlanta's past that point I
mean he's not good I don't know if it's
the majority I mean at Disney World
no not the majority
I mean when you're like when you're
really young
I'm saying like a mascot that you don't
recognize Lando is not really young he's
he's 12 no no I'm saying everybody he's
not gonna cry at a mascot he's just like
I don't yeah I'm not I'm not yeah I'm
not interested
but he's not gonna cower from my mascot
there's a little bit of cowering well
maybe you got to get a mascot costume
and find out
put him in one
that is the way that you overcome a fear
is become the thing that you're most
afraid of he's gonna be like the best
college mascot ever I'm Batman and he's
like I used to be very afraid of this
you should be you should be the next
Batman
the beard won't work
um bearded Batman not gonna happen did
you say what you're afraid of next uh
I'm afraid of tweeting dude I'm just
freaking afraid of it
there's a lot of evidence it's like
there's just these few times that I I
will tweet and and I'm not talking about
like a retweet or like some sort of
promotion I'm talking about like
expressing myself in like in like using
like thinking about things and writing
it out you know I actually think I'm
afraid of writing down thoughts like I
hate doing that yeah because they get
lost sometimes I hate writing things
down uh I hate email but I'm afraid of
tweeting because the few times that I
take a risk it's just like it just
leaves everybody scratching their head
and criticizing me yeah that's it and I
don't blame him that's the internet you
know what because I always learn that
you know what you're right he says I I'm
afraid
of of actually having a thoughtful
discourse with the open internet oh is
that what you're intending to do
sometimes because it is because that
because that feels different than the
way than the way you tweet it doesn't
feel like this is the beginning of a
thoughtful discourse it does some of the
things you tweet you don't feel like an
invitation to discourse it's just like
no I don't know what not not this I
don't know what series of events led to
link tweeting that and it's so tough I
mean it's so tough to know how to uh
like there's so many things that like my
I mean you think about all the issues in
the world and they you know
the people who care about the things
they care about if they like you they
want you to also care about it
especially when it's something that's
like if it's like
uh and
an issue that people need to champion
because there needs to be change and
it's like extremely intimidating to me
so it's like but yeah to take like the
serious route here it's like I'm I'm
really afraid I don't know it's just
like it just it just it racks my nads
man to like care deeply about things but
to not know how to like do it on Twitter
I I it's just
like
there's something and it's the sum of it
is the perfectionism thing and like not
wanting you want to be able to
anticipate criticism so you can take
care of it yourself and not let other
people do it like as a perfectionist you
know there is this fear of
um criticism you know uh so I think
that's part of it but then just like
even tweeting goofy [ __ ] you know is
like I I feel pretty paralyzed on that
front and I think I'm okay with it you
know I think I'm just I I don't I don't
feel like I'm less of because I don't
except the times when I do and then I
realize that I shouldn't
yeah I maybe I should just delete
Twitter
I like it I like I like lurking you
probably shouldn't do it you should
probably not follow 4 000 people you
should probably undo that at some point
um because you got a lot of I mean I had
to go through one time many years ago
because we Jenna helped me with that oh
how many do you follow now
oh yeah I I helped you unfollow things
yeah yeah I don't know how many people
I'm following oh so you reduced the
amount I reduced because we used to like
follow everybody who followed us yeah
and then some of them were taken over by
really weird accounts oh yeah there was
you were following some really weird
things
yeah I think that the um
I completely understand the fear and
they're definitely you're definitely not
missing out on anything by not tweeting
and your life is probably simpler
because of it I but because it's um
it's it's like a part of our isn't it's
expected to be part of our occupation
and that's what makes it kind of
squirrely especially when it gets to
like why aren't you saying something
about this and if you don't that
automatically means you don't
care about it that's not true and
because I do tweet not I mean I go
through phases where I'll tweet a lot
about stuff and then I go through long
periods of time when I don't tweet
I'm currently in a relatively active
Twitter phase
and
you do get this thing where oh okay
I said a couple of things about this and
so now I need to say a couple of things
about this and then of course there's a
another conversation that happens on the
mythical level on the corporate level
right because we're a brand and we right
it is part of brand responsibility and
just part of our personal yeah yeah yeah
uh when we're we're very connected to
that especially when it's things that
like the stuff that I'm talking about
I'm actually really grateful that we
have this we have the mythical account
where it's like we are involved in
saying yes we do want to say something
well and to be clear and there's a way
to say it that like it's not all the
pressure's not on me we have a great so
but I agree but I agree with it we have
a great social media team but the vast
majority of
things that are said when it comes to
sensitive topics
uh or issues that are not just hey go
watch this thing or here's a joke we are
very very involved yeah in crafting and
crafting those messages so and I like
that system and sometimes and it's not
hey you do this for me and especially if
we've taken the time to craft a message
uh for the main account and then I'll
just retweet it right again because it's
just like hey this is me saying
something about this because this is me
and you saying something about this
but but mostly
you're you're so right because
just getting something a little bit
wrong
or even saying something wrong
unintentionally like oh I actually
misinterpreted this or what I said could
be so easily misunderstood
that's the internet everything I say
in life can be easily misunderstood that
yeah and yeah by me as I'm saying it
right you maybe you just shouldn't tweet
that's fine I'll I'll tweet and then
mythical or tweet it's fine you know we
don't all have to tweet yeah I know that
I know that so this is of healthy fear
probably
well now I have to prove you wrong uh
I have a fear of getting sick
yeah you do yeah you do or just
something going this get you know or
being injured in some weird way
I'm a hypochondriac
um and you've never had a big sickness
I've never had a big sickness you've had
some you've had some big injuries I've
had
um
I've had a weird collection of
annoying maladies so like the number of
weird things about my body
that are just inconveniences
you know okay yes I've got psoriasis I
have a bad back
um I don't have a chin that's not really
one of them uh there are multiple things
I can't I'm not thinking of right now
but just I'm in fact I remember going
through like starting at my head and
going all the way through my body and
thinking about the weird things that had
happened right like your elbows are like
weird shaped that's yeah but also I have
arthritis in them and that's one of the
reasons that they're shaped like that
because they're inflamed on a regular
basis they're not inflamed right now but
they were inflamed in the past and so
they like swole and they just stay that
way and so and I've got this weird
shoulder thing or whatever it's like you
actually lost sight in one eye yeah
exactly I've had weird distress happen
but nothing that is uh life-threatening
and nothing the back at times becomes
life-altering and I think it is
the times that
my back has been serious enough to be
life-altering that I'm like
oh man I mean I'll get into a car
and begin settling into drive
and
did I just happened the other day when
we got into a car and I uh when we went
camping when we went camping with Stevie
and the I was driving my FJ Cruiser and
as you know there's not a lot of room in
the back seat of the FJ they kind of
forgot what people were shaped like and
so
I had to move the front seat up to a
place where
my knee is right against the dash and I
said to and I said to you right when you
got in yeah if we are in a wreck my
femur will snap immediately because it's
like exactly the width of this thing
right or what and we know a guy growing
up that was in a wreck and his femur
went through his hip stop it stop it at
the back of his butt
uh and he's ended up having as you can
imagine serious problems for the for the
rest of his life
um I think about these things
to too large of a degree because I
flirted with chronic pain and chronic
inconvenience and then I just think
about
oh man I'm so fortunate that I haven't
had to deal with physical things that
cause
make you have to change your life you
have to do things in a different way
yeah yeah and so I just have this body
trauma fear of
getting sick
getting an injury
and if I
start if you know if I find a mole that
looks weird
and then I gotta make an appointment I
gotta make an appointment with a
dermatologist and then I'll be
thinking about it kind of non-stop like
obsessing obsessing about it until I can
go and talk to a professional and they
can tell me that it's okay and that has
gotten better I haven't really talked
much about my hypochondria in my therapy
but just the process of therapy has made
me better at dealing with it I guess
but yeah that's a constant it's a
constant fear
and I get it man if I were you I'd be
scared too but you don't worry about
this at all you don't have any health no
I just have I have this I have this uh
belief
that
I don't know I just don't I I don't
believe that something's going to go
wrong in like a a moment-to-moment way I
have a belief that like when when I get
cancer or when I when something really
bad does happen I'll be like okay yeah I
I knew it was gonna happen I wasn't
going to waste but I'm I and I didn't
make a decision to not
waste my energy not worrying about it
I've I'm anxious about plenty yeah it's
just not my thing you know so it's like
I'm glad that's not on my list
you know but it totally makes sense why
with like you know you have the you have
a debilitating back injury at a young
age and then it's like okay but I also
think it's just what else is gonna I
just what else is going to happen
hypochondria is genetic my my mom's same
way and the way the way that you process
stuff like knowledge like it's like
I feel like I'm able to like be told
something and then if I again the
compartmentalization I don't if I don't
want that to trickle down into like what
are the ramifications of that of that
potentiality for me like I I try not to
ruminate well it's not that I I find
myself not ruminating on that type of
thing
yeah it's just how my brain doesn't work
so
I'm good with it I'm good with it I uh
uh I have a couple more I'm not going to
mention one because I'm cutting it okay
all right and I'm gonna I'm gonna just
go to I'm gonna give a quick shout out
to Bean uh
really afraid of forgetting something
really important when I'm packing
you know you're on your way to the to
the cruise ship I've never been on a
cruise or the you know you got to drive
an hour and a half to the freaking
airport it's like man
do I have I bought it down to like you
know what I get in the car and I start
driving and I ask everybody in the car
including myself it's like do you have
your ID and do you have your phone if
you got those two things in mind
civilization and do you have and maybe
do you have the charger for the phone
so that you don't you know you're if
you're not at a place where you can buy
one you got the phone the charger the
wallet and like
um you know an enema
you know if you're traveling and if you
just really get you know that can really
put a put a put a stop to the enjoyment
of your vacation if you know what I mean
or your trip
so I'll leave you with that one uh that
feeling man I've forgotten something I
know it
yeah
um
generally
it's commonly called the fear of missing
out
uh I will say
that
I have a difficult time
um
I wouldn't say that this is debilitating
because I'm able to enjoy myself in many
different circumstances but
I am always without exception thinking
if I'm doing something fun I'm thinking
yeah but I could there's something else
it could be more fun
that sucks man you know
um and like did I make the choice
is this thing that I'm doing right now
the right choice when I you know this
manifested itself on the road trips that
I took with lot this past year which I
planned uh and chose the destinations
and the attractions that we would stop
at and if we were at one place
I'm evaluating the experience in the
moment and thinking to myself
okay this is pretty fun I'm having a
good time
but we could have gone to the other
thing that I considered going to and I
wonder if that's more fun and I think
that this is kind of what drives me
almost at like a V you know a core
fundamental level is always just
thinking maybe this other thing maybe
this other thing will be the thing that
is truly is truly fun again I can have a
great time and enjoy myself in the
moment and I'm getting better at being
like you know on the road trip it was
hey
the main thing here is that you and lock
are getting to spend all this time
together and you could be stopping at
the world's largest ball of yarn which
incidentally we didn't stop at
there's or you could be going to
McDonald's and you can enjoy each
other's company and that's more
important I definitely relate to like
that if if if I'm the one who came up
with the itinerary or made decisions
about something that then there's like
choices it's like what am I missing out
on that's like it's on me but I don't
find myself thinking what it
what did they do what did what did so
and so do this weekend I thought I gotta
go even though I don't you know well and
Shepard and I had this conversation
recently uh when I was I was taking him
to
um
an appointment and we had a little time
and we went in to get some coffees from
this place
and they had a macadamia nut latte okay
and macadamia nut milk latte
and I remember we had macadamia nut milk
on the show and we liked it I thought
and he got like a regular coffee or
something
and then we're walking and he's like
yeah that seems like the kind of thing
that you would get and he was like you
always have to try something
you he says I like to just
get the thing that I know that I'm gonna
like
and I was like yeah it that is that is
my personality living in Los Angeles you
know tonight is a date night for me and
Jesse and we're gonna go to some
restaurant that I've never been to and
we always like to go to a new place
even though
it increases the risk of you not having
a good dinner because if you go to a
place that you like and you go back you
know you're going to have a good time
but there's just something about the
unknown of maybe this will be better
maybe it will be different in some way
and that ends up winning out every
single time and I don't it it doesn't
always lend itself to a good experience
because
it's like what Shepard said is like I
I'm gonna he's like I I'm gonna take the
time to drink this thing I'm gonna waste
the time and the calories on it I'm
gonna I want to enjoy it you know so you
a fomo have a mofo yeah so I don't know
I think there's a balance but I'm always
thinking about it don't be afraid
put your fears to rest
hopefully we've helped
at least in commiseration oh those guys
are afraid of that
and look they have a podcast yeah well
and next next week we're going to hear
from you and that's right we're going to
get more specific because we're going to
be talking about
the supernatural disturbing experience
yeah it might not be Supernatural it
might be like the time a guy
you know
try to get and get in your house or
something I don't know we won't we want
to hear the
scary stuff yeah and it's October right
and because it's 1-88 earpod one of
course by the time this comes out we
already have the ones for the next
episode but you can always call in and
let us know what you think about what
we're talking about now so we can play
it at the end of the episode follow us
on Twitter not to see me tweet but to
see the mythical account put prompts out
that then you can call in so yeah yeah
yeah there you go hashtag your biscuits
give us a rack man for the road oh yeah
I'm enjoying a book right now
I Won't Say I'm reading it because I'm
listening to it
uh
uh shoe dog it is the autobiographical
story of the founder of Nike Phil Knight
and it's just a fascinating classic you
know American entrepreneur I can't say
that does it rhyme with manure yeah
story and uh the guy he's a he's a good
writer he's like a super well educated
and well-traveled guy that the way he
frames his experiences is very
fascinating it's funny in places it's
inspiring in other places it might end
really horribly but I don't think it
does because Nike seems to be pretty
pretty big I haven't I haven't gotten to
the end of the story but I think it
works out for him pretty well
shoe dog shoe dog I just turned my phone
back on dude and I I synced my notes and
I have a note called p
with nothing in it and I have a note
called DJ names and it's got all of this
in here
and then I don't have a note called DJ
names two so all that was for nothing
what I don't know I don't know I got it
right here man
I don't even know what to say next week
y'all hey Rhett and Link this is Micah
from North Alabama I wanted to tell you
what scares me the most and it's it's a
little I feel like it's a little
irrational when I was a kid I used to be
fascinated with the book with books
about uh the Titanic sinking and I had
posters and books also I was fascinated
with uh the Loch Ness monster I realized
that it was beaten bodies of water with
large things in them that's what
actually really scares me to death is
this kind of great unknown in the Deep
uh water that that really scared I mean
I've got a Goosebumps right now hey guys
my name is Lily I'm from Oklahoma okay I
have two things one is pretty normal
dolls freak me out I don't know why I've
never had any creepy experience they're
just so freaky and the second thing
that's a little weird is like crabs and
lobsters I've had multiple nightmares
where a huge crab like crawls under my
blanket when I wake up and I start like
kicking and it's so scary I don't know
they're just so freaky okay cool love
you guys bye hey Rhett and Link it's
Ryan from Richmond Virginia on my way
home but I just wanted to just finish
and listen to your latest one and uh
what scares me the most has got to be
Heights I'm also afraid of like people
intensely smiling and staring at you hi
my name is Alex Ramsey I'm from West
Virginia and the thing that scares me
the most
as pregnancy to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]